voici l'arrêté ministériel relatif au
chlordécone
ce sont ces articles que le ministre de
l'agriculture projette d'abroger
il date du 30 juin 2008 et découle de la
ténacité d'un de bon nombre de
spécialistes et d'association un projet
qui risque de faire désordre ne connaît
même pas particulièrement les effets sur
la santé mais je sais très bien que
il est évident que en arrêtant son
contrôle on ferme les yeux et on passe
sous silence un problème qui peut avoir
les effets sur la santé de la population
d'autres bien plus jeunes n'ont aucun
avis sur cette éventuelle abrogation
vous avez entendu ce qu'on dit sur le
chlordécone muffat ils disent qu'il ya
des pesticides tout seul
à part ça je sais pas
mais s'il ya effectivement annulation de
cet arrêté qui rappelons le vise à
limiter les ravages que l'on dit causés
par le chlordécone que propose donc le
ministère de l'agriculture pour répondre
à l'urgence sanitaire les parlementaires
de pnm s'interrogent sur l'impact
négatif sanitaires mais aussi économique
que le pesticide génère depuis trop
longtemps
ils ont interpellé le ministère par
courrier sur le danger de ne plus fixer
le taux maximal supporté par le corps
humain
on ne peut pas aussi grave santé
publique des jeunes femmes des hommes
qui met un bon on peut pas dire on
ignore à ce serait de la lâcheté pur
checker n'en parle pas trop où se cache
derrière le petit doigt ça n'a pas de
sens folle courage mais en même temps on
ne peut pas non plus n'ont pas tenu
compte qu'il faut pas abîmer la
production dans l'abîmé bon ça il faut
mettre les moyens vous les obtenir
les leaders des chambres d'agriculture
que l'on suppose un tiers par le déclin
économique que la sphère chlordécone
provoque dans leur profession ne veulent
faire aucun commentaire
au marché les fruits et légumes pointé
du doigt continue de se vendre
donc de ce document conforme le pôle du
confort la préfecture poursuit les
contrôles réguliers sur les produits
concernés car cette abrogation n'est
qu'une proposition que le ministère de
l'agriculture a émis parcourir